so you guys want to hear something
interesting
so there is a new documentary out
involving atlantis where they did a
lidar scan of the rich shot structure
and they found something
so i'm going to show you a couple clips
of that documentary in just a second but
let me first say that a few months ago i
had mentioned that my next video was
going to be an update on the wrist shot
structure theory to atlantis as i'd come
across a few pieces of fascinating
information that makes the case that
much more compelling
but my gut told me i'm like you know
what i don't know if the timing is right
let me hold off and just play it by ear
from each video to the next and i'm glad
i waited because i've come across a few
other little details that's going to
make the video that much better
now
just a few days ago i made a decision
i'm like okay let's do the atlantis
video next and then two days later i
find out about this new documentary
so bear with me i'm gonna use my cell
phone to essentially point it at my
laptop to show you a few things and
it'll be that much easier so bear with
me
all right so i'm on
nationalgeographic.com
and the name of the show is atlas of
cursed places and the episode is the
curse of atlantis season one episode two
originally aired in december of 2020 but
i never heard anything about it in fact
it was just a few days ago that it was
uploaded onto various streaming
platforms including disney plus so now
the show is getting some traction and
some buzz and people are discussing it
so let me first share with you someone
the interview
which is sarah parkach you may recognize
her she's been on
not just one two but three ted talks
she's been on the late show
and she was on something else which i'll
share with you in a second but she's
famous for doing her space archaeology
they use lidar and satellites and
they're finding all kinds of discoveries
all over the world in fact you may have
even heard me mention uh in a video
about all those maya ruins they found uh
down in bolivia well oh god they're
gonna make me do this see this is why i
don't go to hell but you guys get what
i'm saying here um okay so let me play
the clips for you
and then
here we go
then hundreds and hundreds of features
started popping out if not thousands
in the heart of the ricotta structure
are two absolutely massive
rectangular structures
so look like they have rounded towers at
the end
[Music]
to me that was one of the most
exciting finds
hang on a second
okay so let me just show you guys
something real quick here
so this is a tweet from sarah back in
december 2020 and she mentions you know
some wonderful science was done in
mauritania as the result of this show
i should also point out that she is
she doesn't believe atlantis existed and
she gets extremely apprehensive
about it like
and i'm not picking on her i'll you'll
understand where i'm coming from in a
second
first of all anyone that says with 100
certainty that atlantis doesn't did not
exist it's like okay well um
you can't prove that and it's a
ridiculous statement um but trust the
experts um and i noticed just yesterday
she got into a bit of a tiff
with hold on don't look at that one yet
with giorgio tosukulus i feel like i'm
saying his name wrong but you of course
recognize him he's an ancient aliens guy
super nice guy by the way and regardless
if you like that show or not i think i
could argue
that he may have brought the attention
of various ancient sites to more people
around the world than anyone else
because i mean this show ancient aliens
is seen in dozens of countries and has
tens of millions of regular viewers and
so anyways i noticed that she was quite
mean to him this is just yesterday by
the way i'm filming this on august 4th
2022. so she said some things that
weren't very nice
and she basically went after him and
i've noticed that she's done this to
others before and i just think it's odd
when people get so defensive at the
concept of atlantis existing or ancient
astronauts or anything else but that
aside i'm not picking on her and you'll
understand like i said in a second where
i'm coming from so
here's the thing going back to that
little clip
of
this
wait for it structures
where
do i recognize that let me just go over
to my favorite youtube channel and you
see this video right here
that video i already got the tab open
what's this
guys
october 2018 nearly four
years ago okay so hang on let me show
you another little clip
but absolutely no evidence whatsoever
until now
of any kind of of built human structures
in in and around the record structure
but i think the story has changed
wait for it
wait for it probably date those
you see these
let me let me let her finish her
sentence
eight thousand to five thousand years
ago
okay
let me go back to this same video
what's this
october 2018 guys so hang on a second
like
what's i have a few thoughts here um so
my god what's where's the lidar they
allegedly used lidar at the wrist shot
but if they did they did not share any
of it in this documentary all they share
are google earth satellite images from
in and around the wrist shot which i've
been saying for years yes some people
say there's no
evidence of human civilizations ever
being there and i'm like well that's not
true there are actually um they even
have arrowheads from 100 000 years ago
in the wrist shot which she actually
shares in that documentary but as far as
the time of plato 12 000 years ago well
just stay tuned for my next video as uh
it's it's gonna surprise some people the
things that i share but i'm like hang on
a second now
what you know this documentary
did you let's be real let's go back to
sarah hey sarah
are you watching jimmy's videos are you
did you did you happen to see this one
because again i shared this four
years ago
and i'm just kind of wondering what
where is this thing where's all the
wonderful science
in lidar that was done at the wrist shot
because all i'm seeing is some
some google
satellite images here and by the way you
can see i mean
her sentiment on atlantis i think this
is funny i mean unlike atlantis the
clitoris is real why don't you spend
time teaching male readers how to find
it she's picking on people um and that's
from a few days ago that's actually
pretty funny like i have a sense of
humor um so let me also say something
else here and this isn't uh i'm not
coming after sarah i think her work is
brilliant and i'm sure i'd get along
with her wonderfully but if you guys
aren't she did one of her like i said
three ted talks but she also did one
with the world economic forum now this
is five years ago this is not recent and
it turns out that the world economic
forum even has their own youtube channel
comments turned off by the way i never
watch videos when the comments are off
it's to me i'm like okay what are you
hiding um so i'm not saying she has any
real affiliation with them i mean she
gives gives a presentation talking about
doing archaeology from space so i'm not
like saying she's one of the bad guys
but guys if you don't know who the world
economic forum is or if you haven't
heard of the great reset god this is
something you're going to start hearing
a lot more of in the near future and if
you haven't heard of it already my
goodness you should probably get caught
up because it's disturbing so i have to
say so i thought that was pretty funny
but you guys want to hear something else
interesting so that documentary
they edited out my name and youtube
channel name from that documentary
i don't know why don't ask me how i know
but i found that to be very interesting
now that said my next video is going to
have fascinating details and even if
you're somebody that doesn't think
atlantis existed or if you think that it
did but it's just not the wrist shot
hang that thought
because there are some interesting
details that might even make you second
guess that but if nothing else guys the
wrishot structure is so bizarre it's
still mysterious from a scientific
viewpoint there's so many unanswered
questions about it and if nothing else
it should be one of the natural wonders
of the world it should be explored it
should be researched for a variety of
reasons but all that said i'm gonna go
hammer out my video give me i don't have
an exact day give me about probably
about a week two at the most like i
don't know it's gotta be just right i
want this to be my best video yet and uh
i wanna give it my best shot so i know
it'll be worth the wait and i appreciate
all of you guys's love and support and
if you haven't watched my recent video
on
the conspiracy involving a rock in those
lamas wing bull statues go watch it it's
getting phenomenal reception i'm very
grateful and i think that the content
itself in it is going to surprise many
people but anyways that said my name is
jimmy corsetti my channel is called
bright insight and stay tuned for that
atlantis video real soon take care